all right good evening everybody welcome
tonight's planning committee be my name
is Andy Crump I will be chairing
tonight's meeting before we start can I
ask everybody to switch their phones
either silent or off please because it's
quite disconcerting to be in full flow
and then suddenly the Great Escape
suddenly appears in the background you
know sometimes the captors would wish
for a great escape but unfortunately
they've got a state for the end of the
meeting so if you could do that and also
could I ask members of the public not to
into interrupting when members of
speakers are speaking again however
tempting it might be many people who
were registered to speak can't speak
here tonight thank you sorry about that
sends a bit patch and I was in Shenzhen
at school tea tree and it sounds like
I'm talking to my children but it's not
meant to be like that so apologies if
it's come across not that to introduce
the top table Caroline Nash committee
administrator very nice legal services
Karen Tate and planning manager for
tonight's meeting my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist members
decision taking unbound by the Royal
tram climbing Institute to code of
Professional Conduct planning committee
members are not bound by advice from
officers or by their recommendations
matthew coins senior planning to move on
to our first item on the agenda which is
apologies for absence
apologies received from counseling meals
anthem council Jeunet no substitutes now
again I think we'd have to make sure if
we can try and get substitutes when
people are not available obviously
tonight would call it but it does always
help so if we can pass that message back
to groups that would be good thank you
right item to a disclosure of interest
have members any items up to disclose
tonight minutes minutes of the meeting
at Howard on the 25th of April you're
happy for me to just on them all those
cats fulfilled so yep thank you we'll
pass on those at the end of the meeting
Caroline yeah that's fine yeah super
duper and we'll move on to our first
planning application which is 18002 to
1/8 ful odd Bob on Stratford Road
Locksley Warrick installation of a
standalone of a standalone said the
panels of a stand-up stand alone sir the
panels are we like a next array or too
many panels on surface parking area
dimensions height to meet his debt to
point one meters with 600 for Matthew
will presenting this thank you thank you
chairman the application site is old old
Bob on which is situated to the east
side of the Stratford Road as indicated
by the black dot in the center of the
screen there it's sort of on the road
that connects Locksley through to
stratford-upon-avon so the red line here
indicates the site so you've got a
public right-of-way to the north with
access leading in off the main roads
you've got a dwelling to the sort of
within the center of the site as well as
to the south
just to note that the names of the
dwellings on this plan the wrong way
around so there's old Bob on an old pro
farm
the wrong way around till shown on the
next plan so this is the sighting of the
the solar panels is indicated by that
red dot red square just here it's just
to the north a application site so this
is the proposed plans and elevations for
the solar array so it's 12 miles in
total wind sort of one unit plates 86.4
both sort of 3.1 meters this is just a
view of the site looking from the access
point towards where it's going to be
sighted it be sighted on that sort of
gravel area just next to the barn
there's some more photos yeah again the
the sighting sort of in this area here
this is the access looking back towards
the road this is just an example of the
type of array that would be used in this
location apologies for the blurriness at
that photo taper that's looking from the
sort of the access road towards the site
you can see there's a bit of a hedgerow
along the boundary here and then that
continues sort of around the sort of
back end of the site sort of that
graveled area there's where the array
will be coming okay so the is a detailed
assessment at the application starting
on page 11 of your agenda pack it's
recommended for approval subject to the
condition set out on page 14 thank you
thank you
we'll move on to our first speaker which
is mr. Justin white on
I mean they mr. white on you've got
three minutes would you like a warning
with about 30 seconds to go sorry would
you like a warning with the band sure a
bit much quicker than three minutes okay
far away order hopefully can hear me yes
thank you thank you forgive me the
opportunity to speak on behalf of my
application I would like to erect a
solar system as my contribution in
helping our country become carbon
neutral
councillor O'Donnell has raised
subjection on behalf of neighbors for
impact and boundary issues the impact of
the solar system would be no greater
than having vehicles parked in the area
in fact the impact would be far less
than having a mobile home in order to
reduce any impact I'm prepared to move
the installation further to the boundary
on the western side to take advantage of
the hedge which will provide some more
screening this should be noted that the
installation rail could only be seen
from two other neighbors windows on the
first floor one of those windows is I
think relates to a bathroom
as far as boundary issues are concerned
the installations within the area
registered with her Majesty's Land
Registry as belonging to me thank you
thank you very much catch the barns the
nearest property is that that adjacent
to there
oh how far is it like nearly god I
couldn't
so we've got three three or four
properties yeah yes three properties and
where is the panel the small panel going
square part there on on the top of the
drawing that relates to an old tennis
court which is no longer there the
houses have on it which is it yes that's
the house yes basically the Oprah farm
which is the bull the property down to
the south where there's a orange dog
any further questions
no Thank You mr. white on you're free to
thank you and our next speaker is cancer
doll
so when you're done Thank You chair good
evening committee well this is a
slightly different situation to normal
for me because I actually support both
parties I've lived just in the applicant
regarding the dimensions of the solar
panel when he was struggling with
planning and no he's keen to reduce his
carbon footprint I also know him for the
parish council peers I met briefly
whilst he was actually litter picking so
another valued member of our community
and Loxley and he raised his concerns
with me regarding the location of the
solar panel as I love a stone's throw
from the site I'd really appreciate your
thoughts regarding the application my
warm plant will the two planning
considerations actually given that old
pro farmhouse dates between 1500 and
1700 is a s10 and the impact the solar
panel will have on the character and the
local landscape and its impact upon the
occupiers the neighboring properties the
panel will be seen from bedrooms and the
bathroom which currently enjoys an
uninterrupted view across the fields
where it's rumored that Shakespeare
poached it would also I've been informed
to be seen from the living room in the
kitchen also npp F suggests that
decisions should be sympathetic to local
character in history including the
surrounding built environment and
landscape setting whilst not preventing
or discouraging appropriate innovational
change so perhaps thinking about just
the location of the panel rather than
the concept the panel itself reminder
standing and I'd take advice regarding
whether this is planning or civil there
has been some concern regarding thinning
of the trees and hedges between the two
properties and whether this had been
agreed or not they notice that the they
will see the solar panel as they open
their front door albeit through the
fence and foliage of obrah bond and
unfortunately piers and Amanda have not
registered to speak in time so I will
proceed to raise their concerns with
their full permission by reading out
their statement okay we would like to
raise serious concerns and objections
regarding the following planning issues
and material considerations which we
have regarding the application the
adverse impact the very large proposed
solar panels on the view directly in
front of our house they'd be visible
from the living room front bedroom and
bathroom and kitchen and obrah barn
runs the full length of the front of our
house and beyond over twenty nine meters
in total and within four point nine
metres of our front door in addition the
boundary wall is actually in the wrong
place to our disadvantage as the
original deeds show which only came to
light recently Audubon effectively has a
strip of Ireland a minimum of 1.8 metres
increasing to 2.5 metres in the whole of
the 29 metre boundary regardless of the
boundary issue the view from the front
would have a much less of an issue if
our neighbor hadn't cut down all the
bushes and trees along that party wall
last summer or nearly all of them
against our wishes as we feel it's were
seriously reduced our privacy and all
these trees and bushes were on the
disputed strip we now argue that these
trees and bushes are now dying due to
the reduction of water supply as the
area has been tarmacked by the applicant
we argue we were not an agreement with
the work being done on our shared
boundary regardless of the boundary
issue though and the view from the front
of the house all of the old Rabanne
parking area is directly visible from
the main road and as you turn into our
driveway the solar panels would
therefore be completely visible from the
main road and then all the way up the
length of the adil ik tree-lined
driveway to our property we have been at
considerable pains over the years to
maintain and renovate the rural and
original look of the farmhouse dating
back to the 1700s where we live
replacing the roof we used original
tiles who renovated the original
mullioned windows and maintained exposed
roof beams and internally large walk-in
fireplace as well as the farm well at a
minimum we would suggest that place in
the solar panels out of sight of the
main driveway in the front of our house
ie the back of our barn would enable the
character this special property to be
maintained we argue that loss of outlook
out the bearing impact and loss of
privacy need to be considered and points
1 2 3 need to meet a substantive jected
standard of material harm we feel that
all of the three qualifying objections
meet that standard we would suggest that
you do a site visit
thank you very much any questions for
the water member I must say before we do
go on that boundary issues are not
playing issues that are the civil
matters only so boundary issues are not
to be discussed this is part of this
application
anything else is fine but not the
battery thank you
your indications are if you've spoken to
both sides and worked with both sides if
the solar panels will move more into the
tennis school run behind would that be
something that's the fielding I can see
where you're coming from what we only
have to consider what we have in front
of us sorry about could you I've got a
new picture something else which this
coin might have which would demonstrate
the impact on your not client but your
we have the photographs that were sent
in with their original objection to the
planning department so I have a copy of
those which I'm happy to share again
because they've not been submitted we
can't look at legs on the frame what
were you hoping to see from the photos
because I might be able to answer your
question well the visual impact of where
the location is from the objective point
their chair though that in all fairness
even I'm supporting those sighs that
doesn't give a fair representation I'm
just trying to make it easier so people
got some visual representation of the
matter if you don't want it are no
problem Matthew just take off so it's
not a problem
I'm just trying to be helpful and now
I'm trying to remain impartial so
yeah try not to find the one side to the
other as as a German should do okay okay
that right
any further questions right can't slow
down
thank you much feel free to go right and
we'll go on two points of clarification
to the officer any points of
clarification
Kevin could you just remind me of what
the distance is separation distances
from the neighbor's property I don't
have it immediately in front of me but I
can measure it on the plan if you got
the kind
thank you the the the distance from
approximately there and the line of
sight through to the where the array
would be is about 32 meters about 32
meters from from that point to that
point on the screen
I think mr. White's on mentioned that it
could be seen potentially from his
neighbor's bedroom and on the statement
that counts though Donnell readout she
indicated that it might be visible from
the next door neighbor's living room
is that right that's I don't know just
not yeah that's yes font yeah yep no
that's fine yeah
thank you yeah could you just
sorry you know I don't have that
information from me the neighbor's
property is here and they it's the
neighboring properties here and there is
a there is a line of sight through to
the siting of the the solar panels the
the neighbor did provide some
correspondence with the application as
part of the consultation process and
there is a photo that shows a line of
sight through to the to whether the
array will be if I don't have that in
front of it tonight a photo right that's
the feeling I take it the panels are
going to be sideways on are they do they
well it'll be in that sort of shape and
arrangement and it will be sort of
length on to side on to the
the planet for you indicates that the
the long sides would be to the left and
right see the short end would be at the
top and bottom of the screen on the
frames itself that there's a very slight
variation in height so there's a minimum
height and a maximum height the minimum
height to the freight top of the frames
2 meters and the maximum of Heights
about 2.5 okay so cut Thank You Matthew
so can we just go back to the which way
these these things are facing I'm
looking here at the map on the planning
application which is so as you've gone
up there where is north to the top of
the screen is an indication the top of
the bridge was north so yeah on the
basis they'll be facing south they will
be facing directly towards the
neighbor's property the black screen as
opposed to the backside of it the way
that they're indicated on there seems to
suggest that the this the narrower ends
this way here and here and the longer
ends of this side so they'll be facing
towards the road
can I suggest Christian leaving off
vertically maybe take it vertically then
each other
[Music]
yes you threw the chair the drawings we
have do indicate the rectangle which
equates to the side to the to the solar
panels the short side of the rectangle
is if they're shown on that on the
drawing in front of you yes the
neighbors will be looking at the side
and I will not have sight of the black
glass of the actual panel itself we move
on to the debate just start on this on
them
[Music]
I'll need to come back as well yeah I
feel similar the applicant wanted to
move resented the old tennis course that
would be an open countryside that would
be against policy so as far as I'm
concerned I'm quite happy along with his
opposite recommendation whether it's
proposing or secondly then I'll come
back with my yeah I think when we we've
looked at large-scale set of farms that
has been legitimate concern about the
impact of looking at the glass and any
potential reflection one might get off
the glass here I'm assured by the
Planning Manager that what we're looking
at and things having the slide on is
we're looking on the side-impact where
if the applicant was so minded with a
bit of careful landscaping which in fact
I don't whether we might be able to
querying checking what's in the improved
puns well there's anything about
landscaping
[Applause]
rattling pants careful you think no but
you mentioned something about the
landscaping didn't you always it counts
the field yeah it was me yeah when we've
had these on large-scale solar plant on
the son of there have been objections
about the impact of looking on as a
significant area of glass and they and
reflection both at might have which has
a significant change in this has a
significant visual impact here
surprisingly the way the plans have
drawn it would suggest and I agree with
your suggestion that actually the panel
is facing west and therefore in the
event the side view is the one we have
here there would be an opportunity to
minimize the impact on the neighbor by
either some screening on the side and
I'm wondering whether there is something
that we might be able to condition that
there is some sort of screening because
there is no some impact some of you may
know I do have panels at home there is
no Sun impact of having something on the
side which would hide it from the
neighbor that can come back on to uture
not terribly clear on on where you'd in
busy to landscaping and we're talking
immediately to to this area or between
the two the two point no I'm talking
about actually adjacent to the panel's
themselves so if you move your mouse up
stop there yep and go left and right in
that sort of direction which we commonly
see on new developments where you have
AB in the store where you have some sort
of fencing around it to make it more
visually attractive and here because the
panels are facing west
it could be designed that in any
[Music]
panelling could be designed not to
impact or put any shadow over the
panel's themselves but just minimize the
view from the neighbors window it would
be very minor minor scale I mean the
applicant might be able to do it anyway
but it would I think minimize the
visible impact other than that I would
support second fielding proposal but
with that condition put in I think
perhaps for draw your attention to to
this photograph the panels will sit in
this area approximately in this area so
we do have a push but a change from
tarmac to some of the surfacing that
would enable I think potentially some
landscaping the only thing I draw your
attention to is the overall height
suggested height is a minimum of two
meters so to provide any robust
landscaping to provide screening would
you be looking for something at that
sort of height because certainly we
don't get no don't you like the
shadowing for the solar panels no I'm
suggesting the panel you should the
profile so that has no shadow impact on
the screen itself but actually provides
some sort of barrier so that was not
looking at the supporting structure
underneath it I'm not very strong I'm
just trying to ease away that would make
it more acceptable to the neighbor if it
could be easily achieved if it can't be
achieved then the Soviet I cannot see a
planning reason why this should be
refused but we might be able to make it
more acceptable and planning terms it
will provide it could potentially
provide some mitigation
that would be dealt with through a
discharge of conditions so to attach the
condition asking for a landscaping
scheme to come in the point I think
where the panels about to be constructed
put on site and because otherwise were
in a pre commencement position and then
we would deal with that with the actual
detailing power that was the landscaping
appeared at that point through discharge
application paid to yourselves
yes right then catch the fielding you
did the original proposal with the
additional condition of the garden
landscaping which we've sort of detail I
think I think the condition was that a
landscaping landscaping scheme to be
delegated to offices for their approval
I think I think I think if we give
officers a degree of flexibility thank
you I've seen heard our thoughts of the
meeting assuming we agree the
recommendation and I think it gives them
the flexibility to come up with
something appropriate if everybody's
happy about
we need your presentation are you with
the additional condition three yeah and
that's the second did so we've added a
proposal on a second for that proposal
to grant subjective additional condition
that we've just talked about all those
in favor
that's unanimous chairman thank you
capsule resolves the grant application
eighteen sus two to one AFV well next
item on the agenda which is nineteen / 0
0 3 9 fu our house ships to Lone Star
proposed two-story single-story
extensions a new front porch Thank You
chairman yes the application site is
situated within the settlement of
blackwell
it's indicated by the black dot in the
center of the screen there this slide
just shows the the site edged in red so
there's two rows that bow on the side
there's the in mminton Road to the north
and then there's an unnamed road which
goes along the south to the site there's
also a connecting road between the two
that goes to the west western side the
front elevation the dwellings on this
western side of the property the gardens
to the rear and to the east there's a
sort of a green open space beyond that
so this just shows the existing and
proposed block pans so here you've got
the the proposed for extension going in
and then the proposed two story and
single story rear extensions to the east
of the site this slide shows the
existing of post elevations again you've
got the the new porch going on the front
on the western side and then on the
eastern side of the property there's an
existing small element of flat roof
two-story extension to the property and
the plan is to extend that the full
width of the house there's another
number of other elements such as a
recessed stonelightning that been
blocked up to mimic a window some render
and some other openings as well these
are just the side elevations it's a bit
difficult itself in this plan but the
flat roof extension comes off of here so
that roof is part of the existing gable
that set further back and that windows
reclaimed from the the front porch which
is going in so these perspective
drawings just give a better feel for the
proposed extensions particularly to the
rear of the property again seed but the
flat roof kind of continuing on from the
existing which kind of stops there at
the moment and then a single-story
element going on at the back saw its the
existing it floats proposed floor plans
sees some photos of the site so this is
looking from the south and from the
unnamed Road so the extension would sort
of come out of this area just here and
the new porch was he going in this area
this is the existing
yeah sorry this sorry yeah yeah so this
is the existing two-story element of the
building and the extension will be going
the full width of that at the same sort
of depth this is looking from the north
of the site so again you can just see
the corner at the existing two-story
element here and then that'll come the
full width of the property and then
again that's looking from the Ellington
Road from the north back towards the
dwelling again the extension sort of
going in that area there it's just a
street view to get a feel for it
obviously this is taken at a different
level to the the street itself but it
gets a feel for this sort of the
openness at the back of the property
there okay so there's a detailed
explanation of the the issues on
starting on page 17 if you're a tender
back it's recommended for one one reason
for refusal and that's on page 20 of
your agenda thank you which is
councillor Julie Murphy please from
Reddington price council and apologies
for not being on to here so sorry about
that
we might give you a little few extra
seconds to if you do need to clarify a
few points that eating court here so you
have got three minutes but I might give
it a little bit more leeway to take into
account the technical issues we are
having okay thank you can you hear me so
as one of the three perished councillors
who reviewed this planning application
we concluded the visual impact from the
north and south of the property due to
the topography of the site with high
brick walls mature trees and
outbuildings ensured no adverse I mean
impact on amenities or neighboring
properties so it would be acceptable to
policy cs20 of the course tragedy
blackmail house is a much-loved property
in the village we're fronted on the
green as locals we consider the back
extension designed to be excessive and
complimentary to the building with use
of appropriate materials if at any time
it might be merely glimpsed when passing
we considered it to have no visual
impact on
the overall character of Blackwell or
indeed the house itself and in
accordance with policy s cs9 much has
been made to suggest that the 1.5 meter
flat route projection would be harmful
in the committee report this I would
consider suggestive subjective given the
report has also agreed location
materials fit the criteria for both
policy cs9 and cs20 it is always also
worth noting no objections have been
raised by neighbors to put this into
context as a residence of Blackwell for
6 years myself that lives opposite the
site on the north of the omentum Road
and faces the bottom of the garden it
was actually quite a revelation to find
that the property had an existing flat
roof extension which I could only just
view from my back front bedroom window
if I leaned out this would also be true
should the proposed extension be granted
for the roof on this basis we would ask
consideration to give to grant the
application and that's all I have to say
thank you thank you any questions who
order number Caliban I notice one is
attached building so that's listed what
are the other adjacent appear to me
there isn't a fast building near to the
property so you have I think so I I'm
number one and number two come on up on
the top
so yes yeah so yes okay
so that there is a thatch house called
fat cottage but it's not a fact cottage
sorry I'm creating could you toward them
that before I know your parish can say
sir politics or fielding the photograph
we got of the house showed that there
was a tree on the roadside so these
trees do they protect your line of view
from your property yes very much so
so there's a very mature cherry tree
which completely obscures my view of the
house so it was interesting these voters
were sent to the parish council as well
to look at and this is one of the parts
where you may just glimpse but because
of the height of the verge you very much
don't see the property at all in my
opinion a brief glimpse also it's worth
noting that is also very nice as well
yes absolutely it's a mixture of sort of
concrete and rent I think originally it
many years ago it was probably the same
as all of the very old-style walls in
the village with the cap roof and I
think parts of it had been mended over
time okay
and yeah how'd you say you do the
opportunities comment on that photo at
the price council is the applicant bid
in touch with you on a regular basis
they have you at the dialog with the
applicant about this application no well
not other than we as three parish
counselors with it obviously I'm a
neighbor of mr. Turner's but he didn't
approach you didn't approach us at all
we viewed it separately as we do or and
we always have three different
counselors look at it from different
villages thank you very much
there's the Murphy you're free to go and
can we have our next speaker
she's mrs. Nina Turner
and even mrs. Turner you've got three
minutes and we'll give you a show with
about 30 seconds to go if you're if you
need it sorry I am a bit deaf very well
sorry would you like a warning with
about 30 seconds to go I won't be
speaking for the full three minutes
thank you okay that's fine thanks very
much far away when you're ready good
evening to the committee with reference
to the character and appearance of the
area around Blackwell house the
surrounding properties are a mixture of
styles and periods including two sixties
bungalows and other unremarkable houses
one of these bungalows Celsius also has
a flat roof thatched cottage at the
eastern boundary isn't that built of
concrete with a concrete tiled roof as
indeed is the existing roof of Blackwell
house the hamlet of Blackwell is not in
an area of outstanding natural beauty
hence we have a Business Park a solar
farm and a wedding venue last year we
tried unsuccessfully to sell our house
and the main stumbling points for
prospective purchasers were the lack of
a utility and an ensuite to the master
bedroom something they would expect in a
house of this size our architect address
these factors and designed a scheme
which provides a well laid out and in
our opinion an aesthetically pleasing
family house we are not massive fans of
flat roofs but felt that hiding it
behind a parapet wall and the contrast
rendering softened the appearance and
helped to define this as an extension to
accord with local design guides
certainly none of our neighbors have
raised objections and in any case the
rear of the property is well screened by
pleat trees and a large fir tree plus
the Cherry Tree on the north side a high
laurel hedge to the east and a separate
building on the south side there will be
very little visibility beyond the
boundaries we hope you will look
favorably on our application as we feel
it provides a cost-effective solution to
the accommodation problem whilst
remaining an attractive
property on the green if however you
have any outstanding career queries we
would be happy for a site visit thank
you thank you mister sir any questions
councillor fielding
I got you been planting some beech trees
around how long ago most of us a deaf
anyway so we can't always yeah they were
planted either last year I think they
were put in my husband probably knows
more than me I think they're probably
about six foot I think well they're
still saplings yes any further questions
no mrs. time oh just in time their
cancer kettle is will be any access onto
flat roof from beneath it could be used
for no no that definitely isn't the
attention Lee there is an extension of
the existing flat roof comprises from a
bathroom upstairs and downstairs it's a
little vestibule and so the the idea is
that it's just an extension of that
along the back of the house sorry people
won't be sitting out in some chairs or
deck chairs all right this time you are
free to go thank you very much thank you
and our next speaker is counselor Harvey
who is the ward member I believe we've
got a presentation as well
you've got five minutes so feel free to
start when you're ready I'm more giving
a shape with about 30 seconds to go the
case officers recommended that this this
application should be refused
based on her interpretation that the
proposed extension is not consistent
with the requirements of cs9 and cs20
the core strategy on her interpretation
of the proposed extension quote is
highly visible from the wider area with
the traditional history of the main
house presenting an incongruous addition
on a prominent elevation I suggest that
this interpretation is unreasonable I'll
set out in a series of photographs why I
think this is the case photograph one
shows the western elevation of Blackwell
house the intended extension would lie
to the rear of the house and could not
therefore be seen from this view
photograph 2 is taken from the driveway
of manor farmhouse and shows the current
elevation the property's existing flat
roof is evident this is the only view of
the house where a member of the public
would be able to see accurately the
projected depth of the proposed
extension please note the structure on
the right of the photograph photograph 3
is taken in the same Road it shows that
when the property is viewed from the
street at the bottom of the garden
Blackwell house is completely obscured
predominantly by the two-story building
seen in photograph to that forms the
southern boundary of the property
photographs for is taken from the rear
of the property looking down the garden
towards fetched cottage - view from
fetch cottage it's completely obscured
at ground level although you can't see
it in the photograph there are no
windows in this elevation at the second
floor level to propose the extension
would not therefore be capable of being
seen from such cottage photograph five
demonstrates the corresponding c-suite
scene taken on the north side in a
Lincoln Road from the bottom of the
property's garden the view of blackwell
house is significantly limited by a
combination of a wall shrubbery and a
large trees photograph six driveway of
the house named celsium it best
illustrates the current elevation seen
from the street and is dominated by the
gable end of the existing pitched roof
the flat pasta with the question for
members I suggest is wood these pictures
taken together lead a reasonable person
to judge that the proposed extension was
going to be in the words of the case
officer highly visible from the wider
area I suggest they do not my second
point is that there is already a
precedent in Blackwell for an extension
to a house that incorporates a flat roof
and that it is immediately adjacent to
blackball house photographs 7 these are
the Eastern elevation of selfie of
property that lies on the northern side
of Ovington Road and opposite blackwell
house the photograph shows that the
original pitched roof of this house has
been extended note the change in the
color of the brickwork by the addition
of a flat roof extension to the garage
photograph 8 shows that this flat-roofed
extension extends across the width of a
double garage
the distance that is not dissimilar to
the width of the proposed extension to
Blackwell house finally photographed 9
shows that sell seer also has a porch
built with a flat roof an extension for
which this council also granted Planning
Commission black house is not a listed
building
it doesn't lie in a conservation area
and no local residents have raised any
objection to this application I believe
that the photograph presented as
demonstrated first but the visual impact
of the proposed extension cannot on a
reasonable interpretation be regarded as
being highly visible from the wider area
and second 30 seconds the general
acceptability of a flat roof to a
property in this village is evident in
the extensions already permitted and the
precedent set by the previous decisions
of this council be granted as requested
Thank You chip Thank You councillor
Harvey is spot on
I'd like to see write questions for the
warden of the place I've got one what
you're thinking okay thanks about for
not know this little one five that's the
one with the hedge that no obviously the
hedge is very good for screening from
for the two properties do you know the
ownership of that had shoes whose
boundaries aren't know
Arkan yep no see that that's fine yep
thank you for that that's pretty good
intervention there that's most kind
cancer careful did you indicate now yes
I mean if we could go back to the coffee
one of those pictures previous one
that's not go forward that one is that
the properties that snacks cottage that
is the right householder talk about what
is the impact on the development upon
that house which is not that cottage so
that's that's an outbuilding it's a new
building so we've got there eventually
that's good catch the bonds we are
assuming that that is at the bottom of
the garden yes so it's not if you like
outbuildings he could be anything when I
was taking the photographs I was at
pains to make sure I found the bottom
edge of the garden and took the
photograph from the corner of their plot
because there you have to stand on one
leg did you today that did you write any
further questions how can the warden
only disappear I think you are free to
us
for you to go against the Holly thank
you very much right points of
clarification to the officer case for
the fielding two things one is that the
government have recently brought out the
fact that you can extend your property
to the rear I don't know whether that is
now policy but I would have thought then
the other one would be permitted
development are they either of them
could either of them be made acceptable
in this case under the development
legislation the the bit that you
reference here that's been extended this
year that's single-story extensions
there is scope for some two-story
elements but this scheme wouldn't be
permitted development so there is no
fullback in this in this position the
government policy on developing to the
rear of buildings is that acceptable in
this case I mean it did they could do it
a development under permitted
development potentially but I would have
to be assessed and what they're
proposing under this scheme isn't
permitted development so they wouldn't
be able to do this scheme without
planning permission relation to the rear
extension at the front extension would
that be permitted if I'd have to have a
look porches do fall within committed
vote right so you can do normally up to
three square meters certain to certain
height limits but without having a look
against the regulations I won't be able
to say whether this porch fell within
those through you to the report does in
fact indicate that the officer has no
issues with the porch
yeah okay thank you thanks very much
that will gone to little bites who wants
to cancel Barnes willing to start them
extra bits their window petuzi over
anything else I would like to see bird
boxes included in the and bat boxes
included in the conditions because as
far as I'm concerned it's an ideal place
for that type of animal to grow so I'm
only too happy to propose that
development is approved the comments
about the impact a very apt on this one
and if we look at cs20 there's a
paragraph the alterations and
modifications resisting buildings and
dwellings including proposed extensions
will be of appropriate scale and
subservient in relation of the existing
building I think quite clearly here
we're not talking about a huge change in
in the volume of this property so in my
eyes that is subservient in relation to
the existing building taking the site
location and cumulative impact I'm not
sure what other extensions we've asked
we've asked about on this one that it
hasn't been raised so forget a cs9 this
is adding to the quality of the property
is it is the design strikingly different
the existing property
I think the way that you've got white
walls which reflect front of the house
and the far side of the house very much
reflect the existing style it continues
the format that's already there as
anything I'm slightly six out to me is
the if we're looking at the picture in
front of us the bottom left picture that
white block but since we've been assured
it is we've been assured it can't
perceive my nobody else this will be
private to the property holder and it
can only be seen from their garden so
the impact will have one nobody else
will be will be zilch I mean yes you
can't sit for them I feel quite right
but it'll be it could be no different
and in effect to be moved on that one
you've got something great white wall
there it's just a slightly more modern
feature the way it's been designed but I
don't find that in Congress so I think
that about cs9 and cs20 that the impact
will be both of a quality of design and
the alteration modifications here's 20
paragraph B it complies with our policy
we can talk about conditions shortly mr
Fielding I will join pants live barns on
going daft
I couldn't possibly agree cs9
sensitivity is distinctive I can't see
any other reason be too sensitive
to the building as a whole I agree on 20
B that is again for small alteration or
alterations on the properties the it's
unfortunately the photographs were taken
in winter so it gives a false picture
okay for four or five months of the year
you're going to see it but at the same
time in summer in the spring it losses
into the background so I've got I will
also second or third whatever anybody
wants on this particular scheme but I
think we've got cs9 and cs20 in its
favor so I'm getting the flavor from the
committee that basically you're
disagreeing with the officer who said it
would introduce a prominent and
incongruous feature so you're saying it
wouldn't and you're saying the property
wouldn't harm the character and
appearance of the existent house or the
visual appearance and the character and
appearance of locality so you're you're
saying you're disagreeing with the
officers recommend oh yeah so you're
basically send it will enhance or your
new tenant when I first saw the the
images with the planning officer I
thought I was against it but seeing the
trees and the photographs that councilor
Harvey's produced it makes a big
difference to my opinion on it because I
had you Sarah
I know I see no objection to this
planning application at all so your hope
you support him together yeah cancer
Fleming and I agree with the other board
members and the members of the committee
I see no reason to refuse this if the
kid makes you want to supplant that we
knew some conditions change
yep right then Karen it seems like we
seem to be moving towards a grant and
the reasons because some people happy
with the recent some conditions we are
happy with the reasons for the
supporting application yes so in terms
of reasons you'll be looking at cs20 and
CF 9 being in keeping with the character
the area and their main dwelling yeah
being in keeping with the carrots of the
area and the main dwelling so that
there'd be your reasons for approval and
then draft conditions I've got the
standard time limit plan in terms of
three years in accordance with approved
plans would be looking for details of
the finishes for the windows to be
submitted matching materials for the
main house there's one about the first
floor side facing window that that is
planned to be reclaimed from the front
of the house when they're putting the
porch in and they're going to reuse the
window round there but it does serve a
bathroom so if members are minded we
would recommend that that's obscurely
glazed and then it's whether or not you
want to include a condition about bird
or bat boxes
Kosovo I think contraband did bring up
the matter of ecology that boxes and
Swift boxes everybody knows two ohm's
for the price of one by the river their
scripts pretend this wallets Paris so it
usually depends on for actually ecology
which started bad you look after and you
can have bad boxes but they have to be
in the sunlight because birds dying this
unlike young birds you don't thank you
very much that the birds issue and that
yes so in terms of that issue the
account see ecologists house suggested
using informative but hasn't recommended
any conditions as this is an extension
to an existing dwelling and doesn't
affect any roof space of an existing
dwelling I'd probably say it well yep so
if everybody's happy will will be in
reasonable will put an informative
rather than make it part of the
condition so subject to all the
conditions we've had a proposer and the
secondary and the reasons that we've
we've agreed proposing second all those
in favor of granting the application
please indicate
right committee resolves to grant
application Valentin / 0 0 3 9 5 - Eppie
well thank you for your cooperation on
that one it's very helpful the next item
on the agenda is start time of meetings
it varies art can be reasonably flexible
today was a exception so it did help but
it's all dependent on the members of the
committee over here
yeah probably probably what out 615 for
me interesting go see depends if you
keep quiet case the kettle
so 615 all those in favor
yep unanimous right we have no items of
urgent business so I will close the
meeting but before you go before we go
we will be having a training session a
small training session just to ensure
things run smoothly in the future so and
basically finished it 20 plus 7
no careless